- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(soft music)
- It's a very happy occasion
because we on the
Foerster Lecture Committee
have been trying to tempt
Professor Bynum here for several years,
and at last we have succeeded.
We're very pleased, indeed, about that.
She does need no introduction,
but she's going to get one,
although, nothing like
as full as one could give
or, as indeed, she would deserve.
We always give a brief biography here,
so I just like to tell
you that Professor Bynum
received her BA from
University of Michigan,
and her MA and PhD from
Harvard University,
where she's taught.
At the University of
Washington, where she's taught,
and Columbia University.
In 1999 she became the
first woman to be appointed
university professor at Columbia,
a position she held until
she left a few years ago
for the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton,
where she is now professor
of the Western European Middle Ages
in the School of Historical
Studies at the Institute.
She's received innumerable
awards and honors
including being a MacArthur Fellow,
and in 2001 she was awarded
the Centennial Medal
of the Harvard Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences.
A very, very, distinguished
career, indeed.
So please join me in
welcoming, Caroline Bynum,
who will lecture to us on
Explaining Transformation:
Material Miracles and Their Theorists
in the Later Middle Ages.
(applause)
- Thank you so much.
I'm glad you persuaded me, finally,
to come out here after several years,
which were very busy years for me,
but this is coming to the West
Coast is always coming home
because I spent many years at
the University of Washington,
and while I was there I
had very close friends
down here at Berkeley, many
of whom are still here,
and came down at one point, actually,
to work on a textbook project
with people here at Berkeley,
so I was in and out a lot.
This is a wonderful campus,
there are wonderful,
wonderful people here.
I'm very grateful for the
invitation to be here,
so thank you very much.
Explaining Transformation:
Material Miracles
and Their Theorists in
the Later Middle Ages.
As is well known, miracles
were an important part
of medieval Christianity.
Although protestants in
the 16th and 17th centuries
debated whether the age of miracles
had ended with Christ's ascension,
or with the triumph of
Christianity under Constantine,
most medieval theologians
thought miracles continued
into their own day.
However much preachers might
emphasize inner virtues,
miracles remained crucial
signs, even proofs of sanctity.
Recent historians have
been much interested
in medieval discussions
of the supernatural,
and have agreed that it was
only in the early modern period
that a theory of miracle as an event
that violates the laws of
nature was clearly worked out.
They've emphasized that
theologians after Thomas Aquinas
did understand miracle as
something above or beyond nature,
but they've also stressed
that medieval writers
continued the New Testament tradition
of understanding miracles
and marvels as signs of God.
In the wake of the recent flood of studies
of the marvelous and the bizarre,
much attention has been devoted
to the theoretical distinctions
medieval thinkers worked out
between magic and marvels,
which we do not understand,
but which might be explained naturally
if we did understand them,
and miracles which are done by God
beyond the ordinary
regularities of the world,
but reading medieval texts
makes it quickly clear
that for all the occasional
theoretical distinction,
the terms marvel and miracle
were used remarkably fluidly.
Now I don't want to talk today
about miracles generally,
or even about the theoretical distinction
between miracula, miracles,
and merobilia, marvels.
Rather, I want to discuss a
particular kind of miracle,
the transformation miracle.
All right, the transformation miracle.
This is my subject, so this
is an important definition.
It's a miracle in which
material or bodily stuff
metamorphoses into something else,
often remaining as such,
and becoming a place
of pilgrimage or cult.
I argue that this type of miracle
became more common in
the later Middle Ages,
especially the 14th and 15th centuries.
Some miraculous transformations
were even creations
of the late Middle Ages.
In this lecture, I shall treat
not only their appearance,
but also some of the theories
intellectuals evolved
for dealing with them and
the conception of matter
that lay behind their discussions.
Now, of course, material
objects were central
to Christian practice
throughout the Middle Ages.
Despite the arguments
of learned theologians
that images only gestured toward
the saints and the divine,
people behaved in some cases
as if they were the saints.
Moreover, holy matter was
prominent in other ways.
As relics and contact relics,
sacraments, and sacramentals.
Indeed, such objects
tended to be conflated.
Some panel paintings and
three-dimensional sculptures
contained relics,
hints what modern art historians
would call iconography,
or image of actually
became the thing itself.
You can see in this slide
of the Karlstejn Chapel
that here Christ has a relic
of the true cross in his chest,
a relic of the crown
of thorns in the halo,
a relic of the nail in the nail,
a little bit of the sponge here,
and a relic of the lance
that pierced his side in the side wound.
So, obviously, here we
find that relic and image
have become conflated,
but, conversely, animated images,
and transformed Eucharistic
wafers became relics.
In other words, here you have an image
which is becoming a relic because
relics are embedded in it,
but you also have material
objects which themselves
become relics asserting
their transcendence,
that is their more than ordinariness
exactly by asserting their materiality.
Indeed, we often do not know whether
late medieval monstrances,
that is containers contained relics,
the Eucharist, or other holy things.
If the contents have been
lost, as they often have,
because art historians
are often interested
in the container and not the contents.
If the contents have been lost,
we often don't know what kind
of holy matter was in it.
So parallel, so similar were the ways,
liturgically and devotionally
in which these very different
kinds of objects were treated.
It was only in the period
after 1100, however,
that certain kinds of transformed,
and animated materiality began to appear.
A vision received by
Peter Damian in about 1060
is usually considered
the first case of a claim
literally to drink
blood from the crucifix.
Assertions that bodies were literally,
and miraculously branded with the cross
first appear in accounts
of the first two crusades.
The earliest cases of stigmata
are late 12th century.
By the 14th century
they are often depicted
as inscribings into the
body of the adherent,
not by Christ, but by a
devotional object, the crucifix.
This is a very, very
typical medieval depiction
of the stigmata of Francis.
You can see that the
miracle is not presented
as the impression of Christ in Francis,
it's the impression of the crucifix
on which Francis was
meditating at the time,
into Francis's body.
So it's the devotional
object that has the impact
that is inscribed into
the body of the saint,
and not Christ body per se.
As we know from Katie Park's work,
15th century canonization
processes began to investigate
the physical interiors of holy bodies,
especially female bodies,
to look for material proof of sanctity
such as marvelous kidney or heart stones
incised with religious scenes.
Eucharistic visions were
recounted in late antiquity,
and the Carolingian period,
but, and this is the important point,
these early visions are
accompanied by prayers
that God return the transformed
flesh and blood to bread and wine,
so people will not be
afraid to receive it.
In other words, the
early texts warn against
making any claim that the
transformed stuff endures.
What German historians call Dauerwunder,
that is miracles in which
the Eucharistic wafer,
or the wine is transformed
into flesh and blood,
and remains as such appear around 1200.
They're found in large numbers after 1290.
Now here you have an image
of one such miracle host,
the miracle was alleged to
have occurred before 1433,
they're vague allegations
of Jewish desecration,
but we don't actually know
the origin of the object.
What we have, however,
is the object was given
by the Pope Eugene IV
to the Duke of Burgundy.
This particular pope was an enthusiastic
supporter of these kinds
of material miracles,
and we then what we
have here is a miniature
depicting the miraculous
object in the monstrance,
so made about 60 years or so
after the alleged miracle.
This is one of these Dauerwunder.
In Brandenburg alone, the
area of Northern Germany,
in which I did research for my last book,
which Professor Long
mentioned the Wonderful Blood,
there were dozens and
dozens of such claims
by the mid 15th century.
Most instances of animated
statues and paintings
are 14th and 15th century,
and what is particularly
significant from my argument
is the fact that animated images
are usually themselves older objects
that have recently been
neglected and revived
one or two hundred years
later to reinvigorate cult.
Here, for example, is the
image from Prato in Italy,
which is still venerated today.
In this case it's a 14th century image
that supposedly came
alive in the 15th century
a child supposedly saw the virgin get down
from the wall and walk around,
and he ran and told other
people and they came,
and the virgin smiled at
them and she winked at them
so they got the bishop and the bishop came
and cult was established,
and this image is still venerated today.
Relics that bleed, ooze,
transport themselves through
space, glow with light,
or even create other
material such as manna.
A number of saints
tombs are said to create
their own kind of miraculous manna
that falls from heaven
on devotees who come.
So all these kinds of
objects which animate,
and even possibly produce stuff
are often older objects
newly come to life.
The blood of Saint Januarius in Naples
that has liquified several times a year
since the 14th century is
supposedly a 4th century relic.
Took it a thousand years to decide
to regularly come to life.
Moreover, such transformed
objects were regularly
alleged to transfer
their power via contact
with physical copies of themselves.
Sometimes, clay models
actually made of holy dirt
impregnated with the saints
body or with Eucharistic blood.
So in this kind of case,
where a pilgrim taking away from a site
an image of the miracle
which is actually made
from the dirt of the tomb,
you see, it's both an image
and it's a physical contact
carrying the sacred power with it.
Although free standing sculptures emerged
by the Carolingian period,
and were sometimes themselves
a conflation of relic container
and mimetic representation,
religious art objects of all sorts
proliferated in the late Middle Ages
as village churches became
able to commission statuary,
altar pieces, and panel paintings,
and aristocratic laity to
purchase illuminated manuscripts,
and small devotional objects.
Such objects sometimes called attention
to their materiality
and transformative power
quite overtly by tetchily
which explained that the
devout should fondle,
and kiss them in order to receive rewards.
Here you have two examples.
On your right you have
a devotional object,
which you see is actually abraded
to the point of being effaced
by people kissing the
central part of the object.
Here what you have is a devotional object
representing something similar that is,
the wound of Christ,
and what you have is the tetchily
which tell you that you should kiss it.
Indeed, this is a very interesting object
because the little cross in the middle
what it says on this side
is that if you multiply it by 40 times
you get the actual length of Christ.
Then, if you kiss it,
you get seven years of
indulgence from the pope.
So you can see the tactility,
the physicality of these objects.
At the same time that
all this is happening,
of course, as all of you know,
image hating and image bashing increased.
As did spirited rejection
of relics and Dauerwunder.
This is the period, obviously,
of medieval iconoclasm.
As many historians have noted,
the fury of such attacks
suggests how highly charged is the matter
that must be destroyed in these assaults.
Behind such phenomena,
both enthusiasmm for
transformed materiality
and the need to destroy it,
lay a keen sense that matter is powerful,
hence dangerous because labile and alive.
Now there was considerable confusion,
both conceptual and practical about
this sort of Christian materiality.
In an effort not so much to
explain away this confusion,
which is itself instructive,
as to probe for the assumptions
and anxieties behind it.
I turn now to address directly
what some philosophers,
and theologians said about holy matter.
I do so by looking especially
at a few of the many places
where they treat the topic of miracles.
That is cases where matter,
under the direct action of God,
ruptures the order of nature
God himself has established.
In what follows, as
you see on the outline,
I'm going to do several things.
Having given you examples
of the kind of miracles
I'm talking about, which is
point one on the outline,
I shall now argue, point two,
that the problem of miracles
was to medieval intellectuals
a problem of the nature of the material.
Then, point three, I
shall consider briefly
some conceptions of matter
available to late medieval thinkers.
Finally, I shall argue
that both theologians,
and natural philosophers tried
to use the understandings
of matter available to them
to rein in the miraculous conceptually
without denying it entirely.
In discussing this I shall
underline the basic contradiction
lurking behind all this ratiocination
the fact that the very
understandings of matter
that provided conceptual
tools for limiting change
contributed to a growing sense
of it as dynamic substratum,
yet late medieval conceptions
of material transformation
parallel the behavior of
actual transformed objects,
which simultaneously
proliferated and aroused
increasingly acute opposition,
so the kind of theories that you have
are increasingly trying
to control the thing,
but the theory itself
is making the thing more apt to happen,
and this is exactly what the
things themselves are doing.
These kinds of miracles are
happening more and more,
and yet people's anger,
people's hostility,
people's need to destroy it.
You all know what I'm talking about,
Lollards, Waldensians,
Hussites, this kind of thing,
is increasing at the same time.
In the later Middle Ages
theologians and natural philosophers
spilled a good deal of ink
discussing the miraculous,
but their focus seems to us an odd one.
From the 12th century on the
miracles actually recorded
as worked by holy people
were overwhelmingly miracles of healing,
but the paradigmatic miracles
discussed by intellectuals
were miracles of material transformation,
especially, the wedding at Cana
described in the Gospel of John
where Christ changed water into wine,
and the contest between
Aaron and Pharaoh's magicians in Exodus 7.
Indeed, healings,
resurrections, and exorcisms
were themselves treated as questions
of the manipulation of bodily stuff,
and delineating exactly how spirits,
either angels or demons
might interact with,
and employ bodies received
a great deal of attention.
In the 12th century, Peter the Venerable,
argued that the distinction
between counterfeit miracles
such as those of Pharaoh's magicians,
and true Christian ones
was not only that magic
had a natural cause,
and miracle a cause beyond nature,
but also that counterfeit
miracles vanished quickly,
and take much education to perform,
whereas, Christian miracles
are solid and real,
firmly rooted in matter.
A century later Albert the Great explained
that both the marvelous and the miraculous
result in real transformation
and stated decisively, quote,
the method of miracles is this
the transformation of matter.
To Aquinas it is exactly because demons
cannot fundamentally alter bodies,
that the rods made by Pharaoh's
magicians are only magic,
and manipulations of natural change,
whereas, Aaron's seemingly,
exactly similar rods
are miracles that is real,
and preternatural
transformations of matter.
The 14th century philosopher
Nicholas of Autrecourt,
one of the very few medieval
thinkers to espouse atomism
used a complex argument
about balance in the universe
to suggest that bodily
resurrection is possible
because, quote, if a man who exists now
ceased to exist here in our hemisphere,
and were caused elsewhere,
and, again, ceased to
exist there sometime later,
and then were caused here
he would be said to have risen, unquote.
Autrecourt's discussion is not so much
a fully naturalized
explanation of resurrection,
which almost all theologians
took to be a miracle
as an analysis of the particulate nature
of an eternity of matter.
Even efforts we would not
consider to be physical
were understood as such.
Fascinated as were other medieval thinkers
by examples of action at a distance
the 14th century theorist, Nicole Oresme,
argued that only bodies can act on bodies.
For body acts on another
body across intervening space
what really happens says Oresme,
are examples like magnets
and things like this,
what really happens is
that the configuration,
the geometrical pattern of the first body,
or its member is altered.
That configuration then
alters the medium between it,
and the affected body which
is then itself altered,
so you see it's a physical process.
By the 15th century much of
the discussion of witches
which had earlier involved the charge
that it was heresy to
believe witchcraft possible
came to focus on ways in
which witches might manipulate
alien bodies to achieve physical results,
such as riding animals
or collecting sperm,
and impregnating women.
In the same period, Jean Gerson,
described the great 12th century saint,
Bernard of Clairvaux,
as quote, unquote, invaded by something,
when the power of miracle came over him.
Just as Jesus felt
something go out of himself
when the hemorrhaging woman
touched his garment in Luke 8:46.
It is as if Gerson has to
think of spiritual power
as a quasi physical thing
entering and exiting the body,
although, interestingly enough,
there's no source for
this way of putting it
in the original text Gerson draws on,
so he's physicalizing
it as he interprets it.
My point is not that all these theorists
were making the same argument.
Oresme's theory of
configurations, for example,
was almost unique in the 14th century.
Significant, but modern historians find it
as a step toward
anathematizing of explanation.
My point here is simply to underline
that events and objects understood
as unusual or miraculous
tended to be analyzed
in the late Middle Ages
as material changes.
To intellectuals, miracles
were a matter of matter.
Now, I cannot here give a survey
of medieval conceptions of matter,
and the problems they raised,
but I want to say a few
words about the major texts
philosophers and theologians drew on.
I began with Isidore of Seville
whose etymological dictionary
provided basic definitions
for the entire Middle Ages.
Isidore says
matter is always accepting
with regard to something,
hence we say the elements
are the matter of things
that are made from them.
Indeed, materia, matter,
is named from mater, mother.
It's perfectly easy to see that.
Mater is in materia.
In its essence, therefore,
materia is fertile and
capable of becoming.
Moreover, discussing corpus,
body, and caro, flesh,
Isidore says, quote, corpus
is called from the fact
that something being
corrupted, corruptum, perishes.
Again, you see corpus is in corruptum,
for it is soluble and mortal
and able to be dissolved.
Caro, however, is called from creating.
Corpus and caro signify differently.
Body can be said of something
after life has departed,
and of something that has been
brought forth without life,
and sometimes there are
bodies without flesh,
as, for example, grass or tress, unquote.
Now the way such etymologizing
works in the Middle Ages
is that the structure of
the word is the structure
of the reality to which it refers,
so if something is in the
word it's in the thing
that's how this kind of thinking works,
so if mater is in materia,
materia is maternal,
it is labile, fertile, percolating.
If corrupt is in corpus
then this means that corpus
is that which changes,
so it's the nature of body and flesh
to be passing away and coming to be.
Moreover to Isidore as you can see here
corpus means something
closer to living thing,
or even thing than to human being,
so, you know, all this modern stuff about
the body in the Middle Ages,
but the putty in the Middle
Ages was Isidore's corpus,
it was thing or living thing.
It wasn't necessarily only,
or even particularly the human body.
This understanding of matter
and body that is of both
is by definition changing ontologically
as well as etymologically
change is in things itself
is an understanding that operated
throughout the Middle Ages.
It's especially clear in
late medieval discussions
of alchemy, for example,
when Giles of Rome asked
inequitable question of about 1,300
whether people can make gold?
The possible arguments he
gives for the proposition
include both the fact that
human beings can make glass,
and the fact that pharaohs, magicians,
made servants from staves
are both natural processes.
Giles then goes on to classify
different forms of generation.
Horses from equine menstruum,
bees from the decaying
carcasses of cattle,
wine from grapes,
and gold from other
metals deep in the earth.
The difference he says
is the place and form of generation.
They're all described by him as generatio.
The difference is they're
in different places,
and have a different form,
but it's the same ultimate process.
Now what interests me
about this is the fact
that what we would call normal
physiological production
that is fetus from uterine material,
what we would call spontaneous generation
that is bees from decaying flesh,
and what we would call
mechanical production
that is glass from sand
or possible gold from lead
are treated as parallel cases
in this kind of discourse
as far as the production
of body is concerned,
and that production is
conceptualized as generation.
This sense we find in Isidore,
and much later in Giles of Rome
that matter is fertile,
maternal, labile, percolating,
forever tossing up horses,
bees, glass or gold
was enhanced in the high Middle Ages
by the enormous influence of two works.
The opening and closing books
of Ovid's Metamorphoses,
and Aristotle's essentially
biological model of change
is his On Generation and Corruption.
Following these ancients medieval thinkers
assumed that at least
in the sublunar world
to be was to be about to change.
I give three examples.
Bernard Silvestris, Nicole Oresme,
and Niccolo Tignosi da Foligno.
In the 12th century Bernard Silvestris's
magisterial allegorical
poem the Cosmographia
gave a very Ovidian account of creation.
Indeed as Brian Stock remarks
matter is the heroin of the Cosmographia
fighting death by perpetuating species.
Sometimes, the chaos of
primitive and warring elements
longing to be reborn,
sometimes, a more abstract substratum
Bernard's matter draws from two
rather different treatments in Ovid.
It is both the rough and
teeming mass of Ovid's Book One,
and the perduring, the lasting reality
of the more Pythagorean
account in Ovid's Book 15.
What's especially important
about the Ovid reception
of the later Middle Ages
of which Bernard's point is probably
the single best example is the fact that
poets, natural philosophers,
and commentators
persistently emphasize
the two parts of Ovid
that deal with matter and
change over the more moral,
or immoral stories that come in between.
In the later 13th and 14th centuries
new conceptions of matter
very different from the
teeming mass of Ovid,
or the maternal corpus of Isidore
became commonplace among intellectuals.
Change came to be understood
in line with Aristotle's
doctrine of contraries
that is the idea that
material qualities come
to be and pass away
within a narrow range to
find by the contraries.
Both the principle of change
and the limitation of change
Aristotle's matter is what accounts
for going from one thing to another.
Caterpillar to butterfly, ice to water,
whole log to cut wood.
To Aristotle change is real
because matter is not a thing itself.
Obviously, if a matter is thing itself
it would endure and change
to be only superficial.
Matter is not a thing itself to Aristotle,
but because of potency
to be something else
accounts for particular changes,
changes not inexplicable or arbitrary.
A thing has a potency
to be some other things,
and not other things,
hence Aristotelian
concepts rein in a sense
that change might be completely random
without making change only superficial
because there's something
there that endures.
Nonetheless, understanding
change continued to be
a major metaphysical worry for
those who studied Aristotle.
Nicole Oresme, for example, pointed out
that we cannot even think
without the concept of transmutation.
Commenting on the
generation and corruption
around like a number of his contemporaries
gave a strictly Aristotelian
theory of change
making matter the potentiality to be not A
that guarantees identity and
the change of A to not A.
Oresme said, quote, we say
that the fact of contraries
is the cause of corruption,
and this is proved because all corruption
is by the alteration of the previous.
Therefore, it follows that
every thing having a contrary
is at some time corrupted,
and thus because the same thing
is the matter of contraries,
therefore, they succeed to
each other in the same matter,
and thus matter which
is under one contrary
is in potency to this that it
can be under another contrary,
which, unless it occurs, it would follow
that this potency would
be frustrated, unquote.
Now this kind of an interpretation
might seem to suggest
that unlike Ovidian matter,
Aristotle's matter has no characteristics.
It would then be only that
which accounts for the fact
that we can say we're
dealing with the same thing
when a previous something
becomes a posterior something.
All the essence, the definition,
the whatness of the thing
will be accounted for by the form,
but as Zoe Buzenberg has pointed out
this is not really Oresme's understanding.
Matter to Oresme is not empty potency.
The use of the word frustrated
in the passage I just quoted
suggest, indeed, that matter
has a certain dynamic quality.
It is characterized on
the one hand by privation,
or lack, turpitudo, is Oresme's word
which is a sort of desire for form,
and on the other hand by a
tendency toward persisting,
conatus, is Oresme's word.
Hence it would seem
that even after the reception of Aristotle
natural philosophers continued
to have a sense of matter
as more labile and fertile
than Aristotelian text
taken strictly would have suggested.
Indeed, many of those who used
and commented on Aristotle
spoke as did Oresme
of a kind of propensity
or yearning in matter.
Albert the Great held, for example,
that there was a confusion
in the heart of matter
that could cooperate in the
generation of creatures.
Although some Aristotelians rejected this
a number of theorists such as
Bonaventure and Henry of Ghent
continued to hold to a sort of autonomy,
or actuality or desire in matter.
In the 13th and 14th centuries
then even Aristotelian matter
had certain affinities
with the percolating stuff
of Ovid and Bernard Silvestris.
Moreover, in the 15th century
Neo-Platonic interpretations
which had always accompanied Aristotle
in the high Middle Ages
contributed to the tendency
to give the whole material world a labile,
dynamic almost animate quality.
Although the 12th century
reception of alchemy
had doubted the possibility
of transmutation at all,
there was resistance to alchemical text
when they first came in.
Later authors began to
understand all matter is animate.
The development of the idea
of an alchemical quintessence
led to theories of a vital stuff
diffused throughout the cosmos.
Marsilio Ficino, for example,
related alchemical quintessence
to a spiritus mundi
that is a soul or spirit of the universe.
Using Neo-Platonic theories
intellectuals also debated
the relationship of
heavenly bodies to Earth.
It was after all clear that the heavens
do influence earthly change and fertility.
Tides correlate with
the phases of the moon.
Seeds need sunshine to germinate.
Tadpoles appear quite suddenly
in apparently empty ponds after rain.
Not all worldly change is
as obviously the production
of like by like as is the
birth of puppies from dogs.
I mean, you've got to
explain these things.
Moreover, theories of astral determinism
derived directly from the ancients,
or from Neoplatonizing arid text
contributed to a heightening
and anxious interest
in the role of the heavens
in worldly affairs,
hence philosophers asked
whether earthly changes occurred
through the induction or eduction of forms
by celestial intelligences,
that is through a process
whereby these intelligences
impregnated matter with forms,
or drew forms out from matter,
and queried whether something
like a Platonic idea
was a necessary intermediary
in this process.
Two treatises on Platonic
ideas attributed to a certain,
Niccolo Tignosi da Foligno,
who was a physician and teacher
of both logic and medicine at
Florence provide an example.
At issue was whether
things generated in cases
where like does not produce like
are generated by the
heavens acting directly,
or involve the Platonic ideas.
The examples given in
both Niccolo's treatises
are the birth of a mass from putrefaction,
and the generation of fire
by striking stone and iron together.
I mean, already striking
that these two processes
are taken as analogous.
Now I'm not concerned here with Niccolo's
abstruse discussion of astral influence.
What interests me are two points.
His queries about and his
definitions of change.
Now listen to what these
passages are going to say.
First, we have to note his assumption
that a wide variety of
changes are parallel,
and can be explained as
form acting on matter.
As I just said there's no
theoretical difference for him
between the production of fire from flint,
and the birth of an animal
from slime both are generation.
What needs explaining is the emergence
of not like from like and
how the stars produce it.
Second, we should note
the actual definitions
of matter at play here.
Attempting to sort out the
very complicated issues
raised along the way the author concludes.
If anyone wants to interpret
rightly the statement
form is educed from the potency of matter,
other than it is commonly understood,
he must say that matter is
subsumed under three headings.
First, for that which is pure potency,
which is the non-existent
part of a natural thing.
Second, for a thing which is opposite,
that is for that from
which something is made
so that that from which it
is made is not non-existent,
as, for example, fire is made from air,
and third for a natural agent, unquote.
In the ensuing explanation
the second meaning of matter
is the four elements.
The third refers to that
from which the form is made
in the process of generation
and Niccolo says, quote,
so that the substantial
form which is generated
is educed from the potency of matter,
that is, from the active
potential of the material agent,
and by this material agent I understand,
in the way of the theologians,
every agent which includes
in itself imperfection,
which are all agents
except the first, God.
So you see what's
happened to matter, right?
Matter has three meanings.
First it's the pure
potency that you might say
is in the strict sense
Aristotelian matter.
Second, it is that from
which something is made,
and third is its natural agent
all these things are materia, matter.
Niccolo understands
matter not only as stuff
rather than a simple potentiality,
but also as dynamic stuff.
Indeed, matter is all
the stuff of creation,
forever in motion exactly
because imperfect in contrast
to the perfection of God,
so by this point the whole universe
has become materia in a sense.
Now this understanding of
matter is in some sense dynamic
as possessing power or desire within it
does not run in a straight line
from the Neo-Platonic and Ovidian writings
of Bernard Silvestris and his
12th century contemporaries
to 15th century figures
like Tignosi and Ficino.
The 13th century recovery of Aristotle
did make a difference,
and as I suggested Aristotle's
matter is not a substance,
hence it's less labile in itself
than the matter of 12th
or 15th century theorists.
Moreover, 14th century
scholastics such as Oresme
were less concerned with matter per se
than was, for example, Bernard Silvestris.
They were suspicious of
ideas of animate matter
whether alchemical or cosmological,
although, change especially
in the form of local motion
remained a pressing question for them.
The theories of matter we
find in natural philosophy
from the 12th to the 16th
century are not all the same,
nor they do show a continuous development
from the world soul
of some 12th century commentators on Plato
to Ficino's soul of the universe.
Nonetheless, even the theorists
of the 13th and 14th centuries
who opposed the possibility
of living stars,
or alchemical manipulation
tended to assume almost
in spite of themselves
a basic dynamism lurking in men.
Now this kind of understanding of matter
I've taken you on a brief
tour through the Middle Ages,
but I think if we're
gonna talk about theories
you have to understand
the theories and the base.
This understanding of materiality
was theologically speaking a problem.
If matter was by definition
the great roiling mass
of Ovid's Metamorphoses,
or even the active potential
of Foligno's material agent
then the eruption of the
sacred in Dauerwunder,
for example, or in animated
statues was easy to envision.
Its continuing presence,
its stasis or endurance
became difficult of explanation, however.
If things were always coming to be
were they not also always passing away?
To Isidore, after all, corpus
was related etymologically,
and thus ontologically to corruptum,
that's what it is to be a thing,
and was not such passing
on such corrupsio a threat
if it touched the divine.
Remember talking about miracles
where the divine appears in matter.
In the controversy over the
miracle host at Wilsnack,
for example, there were
theorists such as James of Klusa
who claimed not only that
the deteriorated stuff
revered in the 1450s could not be sacred
because it had decayed,
but also that if it later decayed
it could not have been
holy in the first place,
so when it appeared in 1383 looking back,
you know, retrospectively you say
it couldn't have been holy then
because now it has
decayed God cannot change.
His body does not appear and disappear,
so clearly the fact that sacred things
pass away was a problem,
but even coming to be was a problem.
Materiality needed to be controlled,
conceptually and ecclesiastically.
Neither church authorities and theologians
nor natural philosophers
could tolerate a world
in which anything might erupt anywhere,
hence they devised
theories that controlled
that has limited miraculous
change in a variety of ways.
They did this sometimes by reducing it
to mere appearance of transformation,
sometimes by admitting it,
but hedging it about with explanations
that involved as little change as possible
is to this point the efforts
of theorists to rein in
the miraculous without
denying it that I now turn,
this is part 4B here on the outline.
So I'm not arguing that here these guys
they're just naturalizing miracles.
If they were that wouldn't
be all that interesting,
you know, I mean, once
Hume says it he said it,
but what's interesting is that they can't
naturalize miracles completely,
but look what they're doing
in order to rein them in
in all kinds of ways
short of simply denying,
or naturalizing them.
A number of theologians
held that Dauerwunder
were not real change of
accidents that is appearance.
The real change in the
Christian Eucharist was,
of course, the substantial
change of bread to flesh,
but this was invisible.
Indeed, it was part of the definition
of transubstantiation that
accidents do not change.
Hence most theologians
held that if an individual,
or a group saw a host or
communion chalice change to blood
they were not seeing
the substance of Christ in the Eucharist,
but an effect produced by
God in their imaginations.
So the theorists are in a way
substituting one kind
of miracle for another,
but you cannot see God
in transubstantiation
because it sits under the
definition of transubstantiation
that you can't see the substance,
and the accidents don't change.
Dauerwunder might be miracles,
but they were not miracles of seeing God.
Building on theories that went back
to Augustine of Hippo,
theologians by and large
made similar arguments about
the bodily metamorphoses
that so fascinated late medieval people,
the change of humans into animals,
or werewolves supposedly
caused by witches, demons,
heredity, sin, or the moon.
For example, Heinrich
Kramer, in the notorious
Malleus Maleficarum, the
Hammer of Witches of 1486
argued that witches could make men believe
they had lost their genitals
by hiding them from view,
or act on the senses and the
imagination to delude people
into quote, unquote, thinking
they see marvelous things
such as beasts or other horrors,
when in actual fact they see nothing,
but witches cannot in a strict sense
turn people into beasts,
thus some intellectuals between
the 13th and 15th centuries
dealt with the supposed
miraculous miracle,
magical or marvelous changes
by claiming them to be the mere appearance
of transformation or
one kind of appearance,
and another sort of miracle,
but theologians and natural philosophers
also limited or naturalized
the physical changes
involved in miracle.
We see this in two moves
first explaining physical
change by internal mechanisms
even if they're used supernaturally,
so you keep some kind
of supernatural element,
but you actually come up
with a natural explanation
for the change even if it
takes God to trigger it.
Second, explaining bodily
occurrences even in
Christ's body by natural
physiological processes.
The first move made use from
the 12th to the 14th centuries
of an idea inherited
from Augustine of Hippo
that felt particularly
well with an Ovidian sense
of nature as a percolating mass of forms.
This was the idea of seminal reasons.
Seeds of later things or incipient forms,
or patterns of development
implanted by God at creation.
The idea that bodies bore
seeds of other bodies
they might generate or become
was used by a number of
intellectuals to explain miracles,
or elucidate doctrine such
as transubstantiation.
It was an idea that closely
controlled the nature,
and direction of change without as I said
naturalizing the miraculous completely.
In the 12th century, for example,
both John of Salisbury and Rupert of Deutz
explained the miracle at Cana,
thus that is the change
of water into wine.
There are seminal reasons
in things that unfold
in preordained time.
Trees draw up water into
grapes and make wine.
If God speeds this up
and turns water into wine
without the intervening
steps we call it a miracle.
In a way you've got a natural explanation
the divine element is the speed up.
Theories of similar reasons
lasted into the 14th century,
but there were other concepts
that could be used to limit change.
Hugh of Saint Victor seems
to have had a theory of atoms
that explained the production
of Eve from Adam's rib,
and as I said earlier
Nicholas of Autrecourt
explained resurrection atomically
by that vaporization and recondensation.
Roger Bacon gave an
analysis of resurrection
as the reduction of body to prime matter,
and the induction of the same form again.
Although not denying the miraculous nature
of the event entirely
this discussion analyzes it
in terms of a natural process
like that debated by
contemporary alchemists.
Oresme commenting in the
Generation and Corruption
naturalized the effects of the Eucharist,
but not the Eucharist itself arguing
it is a miracle that accidents
are present without a subject,
but not, however, a miracle
that these accidents
act on other accidents or substances
hence the Eucharist can
feed those who eat it.
In addition to such models
as some of the reasons
atoms, configurations that
can be employed to explain
extraordinary or miraculous change
a number of late medieval theologians,
and natural philosophers
used physiological theories
such as the traditional
Galenic idea of the humors
to categorize anomalous bodily events.
Around 1300 there was, for example,
discussion of whether the bloody sweat
Christ shed on the Mount of Olives
was naturally or supernaturally produced,
and whether his death on the cross
was a result of bleeding
or an act of his will.
15th century debates about
the relics of Christ's blood
at places such as Westminster,
Weingarten La Rochelle,
entailed determining whether the blood
Christ shed on Golgotha
was superficial nutritional
blood generated from food,
or the blood of the so-called
core of human nature.
You'll probably be glad
I'm not gonna explain
these debates in detail,
but the interesting thing
is that scientific theories
are being employed not as I
say to completely naturalize,
but to go a long way towards naturalizing,
so that you can understand
scientifically the process
that's going on even as I
say if God has to trigger it.
They did similar very interesting
sort of discussions with stigmata,
which come close to some kind of
maybe even modern sort of
psychological understandings
because they talked
about how the imagination
between the upper and lower
elements of the intellect,
and the body God would
have to cooperate with it
in order to produce physiological effects.
In order to give you one
more detailed example
of how medieval intellectuals
use theories of matter
to limit without denying miraculous change
I turn to an example,
and I'll talk about a little bit more,
and this is my last example.
This is Jan Hus's two treatises
on Christ's blood from 1406 to '07.
Treatises that were produced
for the Ecclesiastic Commission
appointed in Prague to
look into the claims
of the Wilsnack miracle.
Here just incidentally is the
Wilsnack church as it today,
and the chest where these
miracle hosts were kept
in the 15th and early 16th centuries
before the actual miracle was destroyed.
Hus dismissed effluvial relics
such as the holy foreskin,
and the blood of Christ
laboring them near visible
signs for the faithless.
He rejected as fraudulent
transformation miracles
that were associated
with the Wilsnack host.
It supposedly had produced
resurrections from the dead.
It had turned staves into
swords, and vice versa,
this kind of thing he rejected all this.
He suggested that preserving
supposed blood relics,
and host miracles was akin to, quote,
venerating horse's blood smeared on wafers
by lying priests, unquote.
To revere such bits of
matter was to denigrate God,
yet Hus admitted the
absolute power of God,
and that it could cause Christ's blood
to remain behind on earth.
By the theory of Concomitance
that is the theory that
part is whole Christ's
blood is wholly present
in every celebration of the Eucharist,
hence it could be on earth as
well as in heaven in glory.
Hus employed technical
Aristotelian terminology,
and natural philosophical analogies
to explain the possibility
both of blood relics,
and of another singularly
unnatural occurrence
the resurrection of the
body at the end of time.
Apropos blood relics Hus asserts
that redness might remain
on tunic that is Christ's tunic,
or the sweat cloth or on
the bread of the Eucharist
apart from the substance of Christ's blood
just as accidents remain in the Eucharist
when the substance changes,
so it's a kind of
transubstantiation but in reverse.
In transubstantiation
the substance changes,
but the accidents stay bread and wine.
Here the idea would be that
the accidents of the blood
can appear on the miraculous objects,
but the substance of
Christ's blood is not there
because it's in heaven,
so this is a possible explanation.
He insists, however, that if
this kind of redness appears
the redness would be a
miracle caused by God,
but only, quote, unquote,
left in memoriam, unquote.
In other words,
he has to admit the
possibility of blood relics,
but he uses technical
substance accident language
both to explain the possibility,
and to claim that the present redness
even if created or permitted by God
is not the substance of Christ.
Apropos the blood of Christ's
circumcision, Hus writes,
quote, and it is possible
that the blood of Christ,
which flowed out from his
body in the circumcision,
was substantially converted
into something else
according to form,
or that the blood if
drained out on the cross,
and converted to vapor
by the heat of the sun
reverted then by his power
on the day of resurrection
to its proper form,
and this was the same
blood in number as in form,
nor should the faithful fear that
they will not receive again their bodies
because wild animals have eaten them
for in the resurrection all
will be gloried, unquote.
Now there are a lot of interesting
things in that passage.
We see Hus using Thomistic
notions of formal identity,
how something can be
the same thing over time
because the form is the same
as the philosophical argument,
and natural philosophical
understandings of vaporization
to render the miracle
of bodily resurrection
as credible as possible
logically and scientifically
because form carries what a thing is,
the return of substantial form to matter,
which has in the meantime
had another substantial form
can make the entity the
same thing it was before.
Things converted to gas or vapor
by the sun can recondense,
so philosophical argument,
scientific argument,
hence even the blood shed
in crucifixion days before,
or in the circumcision years
before, 32 years before
can be reassembled for resurrection
just as moisture returns out of the air,
and at a technical sense
it will be the same
salvific blood of Christ.
Now, Hus's point is not,
of course, to limit material change,
or to rein in the miraculous per se.
To him the devotional and
theological agenda is paramount.
What he wants to restrain is false piety.
What he asserts most passionately
is the soteriological
significance of the
resurrection of the dead.
He uses the natural
analogy of vaporization
to assert that all Christ
blood rose with Christ
because he wants to limit pilgrimage
to blood relics and Dauerwunder.
He uses Thomistic language
of form and substance
because to him the return
of bodies at the end of time
is central to the Christian
hope for personal salvation.
His argument constrains one
kind of miraculous change,
the eruption of blood on sacred objects,
but supports another,
the resurrection of every bodily particle.
Moreover, he employs the
language of formal identity
to bolster faith in God's power
to do the truly astonishing,
raise the dead, although,
he denies that God did so at Wilsnack.
Using metaphysical and
scientific language,
Hus restricts certain
kinds of miraculous change
while supporting others.
He demystifies, makes
intellectually accessible,
even naturalizes certain
aspects of holy matter.
What he does not do is
either deny God's power
to transform matter or leave
it without explanation,
and I argue this is a typical
14th and 15th century move.
Now I could give many more examples
of such types of
argumentation, but I won't.
I hope I've now demonstrated
that behind the discussion
of university theologians,
devotional writers,
and natural philosophers about miracles
lay a quite ambivalent
fascination with material change
that coincides with the
contemporary proliferation
of transformed images,
relics and Dauerwunder,
and the increasing anxiety about them.
Chronology is important,
although, for such changes in attitude
it is necessarily not very precise.
People don't wake up one morning,
and have different attitudes
from those they had the day before.
Nonetheless, I must underline that it is
in the 14th and 15th
centuries when Dauerwunder,
and other transformation
miracles proliferated
accompanied by theological
efforts to deal with them
that we find a shift in
other sorts of theorizing,
whereas, in the 12th and
early 13th centuries,
the newly received alchemical texts
were accompanied by glosses
that suggested that
alchemy was not possible,
that species were enviable.
By the 14th and 15th century
there was growing confidence
that species could be transmuted,
gold could be made if only the
correct formula were found.
12th century ideas of a world soul,
or of matter as Ovidian fecundity
were succeeded in the late
13th and 14th centuries
by a more Aristotelian
focus on locomotion,
and opposition to ideas
of a living heaven,
but these were followed
in the 15th century
by the return of Neo-Platonic ideas
of the soul of the universe.
12th century stories of werewolves,
and other bodily transformations,
although, very popular
insisted that such changes
were basically only apparent.
By the later 15th century
some theorists tended
that people really became wolves.
There continued to be
resistance to the idea that
witches actually turned
people into beasts,
or snatch away their body parts,
but they were increasingly persecuted
for creating widespread
illusions of change.
Some among them and
among their persecutors
did believe they could
cause such metamorphoses.
By the later Middle Ages
astrology flourished,
and intellectuals devoted
a great deal of discussion
not only to ways in which the stars
controlled earthly events,
but also to material changes
they caused here below
such as the birth of
hermaphrodites and monsters.
In conclusion then
the end, in conclusion
I'm arguing that claims to
miraculous transformation
increased in the later Middle Ages
as did suspicion and rejection of them,
and that medieval natural
philosophy provided
both a sense that matter is that
in which radical change erupts,
and a set of conceptual
tools for containing
if not naturalizing
completely such eruptions.
I would also suggest
that these developments
of this complicated kind of contradiction
foreshadow and in some ways lead into
the 16th century religious
upheavals we call reformations,
but to discuss that would
be to give another lecture.
Thank you.
(applause)
(soft music)